how much power does he retain donald
trump
because that'll tell a lot i mean is it
is it the end of training day where
denzel washington is like
i'm king kong up here and they're like
no you're not anymore
no you are not you your power is gone
the russians or
the bridge it remains to be seen i mean
i think there's already some indication
that some of trump's base of support
seems to be eroding his brand is
i win i go out and i win right he very
much lost and there may be a narrative
out there about him having one
but a lot of folks are not buying that
anymore even if it takes a little bit of
time for the polling to catch up with
that you know nixon leaves office
republicans are still a little high on
him maybe a little less reluctant to
acknowledge the awfulness thereof
eventually but you know he's they say
he's starting this patriot party
that's the name of it that first of all
that sounds like nazis to me
and not like they're killing all the
jews nazis but like fascism come to
america
patriot party whenever you are that
blatant about where the patriots
were the good people do you prefer trump
organization as the name of this
new entity i i actually would yeah
patriot party is very brown shirty
and i do worry that you know all those
people who
just believe might is right who you know
we're
at least two generations past where they
taught anything in school
so it's not like people know that
they're violating the constitution
because they have no clue what's in it
to begin with
so they don't know they're fascists but
they are
and i feel like they're all going to be
in the patriot party
well and it's going to be a dangerous
talk about fifth columnist
i think it i saw some people on twitter
sort of snickering about the idea of
trump creating a patriot party
um in part because trump doesn't
necessarily have the work ethic and
attention span to do such a thing but
trump university trump stakes right
patriots however but he has people
around him he was 100
no i'm not i take it somewhat seriously
actually you saw all of these people in
the conservative
universe from lou dobbs to charlie kirk
say this is a good idea
if if anyone can get ballot access
raise small donor money uh
have support in every single state
outside of a political party
it's donald trump the problem is you
know it would just
deprive him i think in a different way
of power i mean the way
for trumpism to reach success is to do
the hostile takeover of the republican
party to win republican primaries
and then win elections i mean a patriot
party would hold down
republican votes as a third party in a
general election it would just allow
democrats
to win because it would just siphon
those voters out of the republican
party another avenue is to take
advantage of one of the other third
parties that already exist not the
libertarian party that is near and dear
to my heart
but perhaps the reform party or
something like that but
in in either case i am far more
skeptical of this proposition i think it
actually takes a great deal of
organization and if there's anything
we know about donald trump he's not
terribly well organized and in terms of
spending money but i absolutely spend
money on other candidates i must tell
you gentlemen this does sound like the
same i heard before he became
president
donald trump's just a buffoon he's not
serious about president he'll never do
this he'll never do that and then he did
it all and here we are
access is a little bit different than
having rain name recognition
having had a television show this is
very different i i will say one thing
though
though the notion of sort of referring
to these people as fascist broadly or
even donald trump is a fascist
i often worry about giving the man too
much credit
and i worry about using words that are
highly charged that
may not in fact illuminate the
conversation in the way that we really
accept it yeah i agree with that in
theory but you know there's a lot of
definitions of fascism
i've heard many over the years some from
learned people disagree
but i think the one thing we can all
line up behind it is this idea of might
makes right
and that we don't respect democratic
norms if you can't call
what the people who wanted to undo the
election
that even the republican judges and
politicians said was fairly
called i i don't know what fascism is
i then what definition do we have for it
i mean that that is fascism when it's
just like
i mean because they're not a lot of
these people even the republicans in
congress
they're not sorry about what happened on
january 6th they're just sorry it didn't
work
you